on the troughs of July my term is
Eurogroup president will come to an end
in the past two and a half years against
the backdrop of sustainable economic
growth we have reduced risks and made
progress on completing our institutions
under my leadership we turn the page on
austerity while closing all deficits
procedures we closed the Greek program
with a sizeable debt relief package and
we prevented a defiant budgetary stance
in Italy from unleashing another
financial crisis we improved the euros
resilience with our footsteps to
future-proof our currency a reform of
the SM Treaty is ready to be signed a
eurozone budgetary instrument was set up
from scratch discussions on a European
Deposit Insurance Scheme were unlocked
when a new crisis came the group took
the lead without hesitation and in
record time we created a powerful safety
net for workers businesses and countries
and agreed the key features of a
recovery fund that will be an
integration leap in this period the UK
left the Union but we laid the ground
for Croatia and Bulgaria to join the
euro the Euro group became a more
effective crisis manager and also
reinforced its role of steering economic
and fiscal policies in good times by
building mutual trust
we made all these achievements possible
and this makes me confident about
Europe's future
you
[Music]